>> WHAT'S GOING ON EVERYBODY
WELCOME TO ANOTHER WEEK FIVE
WEEK SPIRITWEEK SIX.
IT'S ALWAYS A GREAT DAY.
I WANT TO GOTHTHROUGH SOME KEY
INJURY NEWS AROUND THE NFL WE
ALWAYS HAVE MORE INJURIES TO
DEAL W WITH UNFOUNATELY.
WE HAD LAST SUNDAY OM ESPN
THAT HE HAD A GOOD CHANCE YET
TO RETURTHE PRACTICE WITH
THAT FOOT INJURY.
COMING BACK TO A LIMITED
PRACTICE.
I WOULD THINK WITH THPROTOCOL
RULES GOING ON.
BASED ON  THE PRACTICE
PARTICIPATION HE MIGHT HAVE THE
BEST PRACTICE.
HE WAS MESSING UP HIS RIGHT
THUMB STILL TECHNICALLY
EXPECTING HIM TO BE UNDER
CENTNTER IT GHT BE A FINAL LINK
BACK AND REY TO GO BY WEEK
SEVEN.
VERY MUCH LIMITED WITH THAT
HAMSTRING INJURY.
THAT IS FINALLY STEVENSON ON
ONE SEASON.
COMING UP IN ALL SHAPES AND
SIZE
STILL PRACTICING WITH THAT FOOT
INJURYRY. I GET IT IT'S A TOUGH
TIME RIGHT THERE.
THE CHANCE IS STILL ON THE WIRE
ALSO JONATHAN TAYLOR BACK ON
PRACTICE DEALING WITH THAT
ANKLE INJURY.
IT'S AN ATROCITY AGAINST THE
BRONCOS.
JONATHAN TAYLOR GETTING BACK
THERE DOING EVERYTHING AGAIN.
GET BENJAMIN. IFHE'S AVAILABLE,
KEEP WATCHING WE ALWAYS ENJOY
HAVING HIM HERE.
HE IS SETTING UP TO BE A
FEFEATURED BK IN ARIZONA THIS
WEEK.
THEY ARE ALREADY RULED OUT WITH
A KNEE INJURY SO -- I
UNDERSTAND THIS ARIZONA
BACKFIELD THIS WHOLE OFFENSE
ACTUALLY.
WE HAVE TO SEE CONSISTENT HIGH
PERFORMANCES THERE'S ONLY A
HANDFUL OF COACHES REALLY GOING
TOET THEIR OVERERALL ROLE
THEY HAVE BEENONE OF THEM OVER
THE YEARS SO MAKE SURE YOU KEEP
AN EYE ON THE INJURIES THEY ARE
ALWAYS UPDATING.
YOU CAN CHECK IN OUR PODCAST ON
FRIDAY WHERE I COULD YOU
COVERED WITH ALL OF THE
INJURIES EACH AND EVERY EK
BUT WITH THATAT SAID EVERYONE
LET'S GET THINGS STARTED THIS
IS FANTASY LIVE PRESENTED BY
STATE FARM.
PANIC OR RELAXED IS THAT THE
MOTHER SHALL.
WE ALL HAVE A PLAYER ON OUR
FANTASY THEME.
IT'S ONLY BEEN FIVE WEEKS WE
DRAFTED THEM FOR REASONS SO FOR
THAT REASON HAS NOT COME TO
FRUITION.
AND HERE TO HELP YOU FIND OUT
WE HAVE DIFFERENT PLAYERS GOING
TO TO DETERMINE JUST THAT
STARTING THINGS OFF THE LOS
ANGELES RAMS QUARTERBACK JUST
THIS SEASON.
NOT EXACTLY WHAT WE WERE HOPI
FOR.
HE WAS BEING PRIORITIZED WELL
AHEAD OF HER GUYS LIKE SMITH
AND RSON GUYS THAT ARE GIVING
US MORE FANTASY POINTS NOW SO
AND HAS BEEN BRUTAL GUYS.
ON A WEEKLY BASIS Q.V.
29 AND MOST RECENT 15.
THE VOLUME HAS ACTUALLY BEEN
THERE OVER THE LAST TWO WEEKS
ONLY BRADY AND MATTHEW HAVE THT
JOB BACK THE HOPE IS THAT THE
OFFENSE CAN'T STAY. IT'S EVEN
THE WORST VERSION OF JARED WITH
THE OFFENSE IT REALLY WASN'T
IS BAD.
YOU LOOK AT THE OVERALL SCORING
SINCE 2017 FIRST, SECOND, 11/22
AND SEVENTH LAST SEASON.
THE BIGGER CONCERN FOR THE
OFOFFENSE SHOWS THE LACK OF
ANHERE TO GO IF IT'S NOT
BEING THROWN.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT ROBINSON A
LITTLE BIT MORE IN A BIT BUT SO
FAR THE OFFENSE stWITH PASS
BLOCKING AND 31st IN MESHING.
THE 28th PAST HASN'T EXACTLY
BEEN HELPING THINGS THE THING
IS LONG AND STRAIGHT CATCHABLE
DEFENSE IN THE ENTIRE LEAGUE
WITH TH IN MIND WE HAVE OUR
PANIC METER.
>> I AM PANICKING I'M NOT
RELAXI.
THIS OFFENSE LOOKS COMPLETELY
BROKEN AM NOT SO SURE SOMEONE
LIKE JEFFERSON IS COMING OFF OF
THAT WITH AN ACL TEAR EVEN IF
HE DOES RE-SIGN FOR THE RAMS
IT'S NOT JUST ON STAFFORD IT'S
ON THE ENTIRE OFFENSIVE LINE
FOR THE RUNNING GAME.
HE IS UNABLE TO GET THIS OFFENSE
TO LITERALLY JUST THE AVERAGE
THAT'S THE PROBLEM HERE.
YOU HAVE THE EXPECTATIONS
ASSESSING STAFFORD IT'S REALLY
A BOTTOM FIVE OFFENSE IN THE
NFL L RIGHT NOW I DON'T THINK H
WILL BE COMPLETELY UNUSABLE BUT
IT'S TIME TO ADJUST YOUR
EXPECTATIONS AND START TREATING
HIM FAR MORE AS A MATCHUP FOR
SOMEONE AT CAN START EACH ANAND
EVERY WEEK.
I LOVE YOU GUYS IN THE CHAPTER
THUS WE WILL GET TO ALL YOUR
QUESTIONS THROHOUT THOUGHTS
ON HAWKINS WHEN HE RETURNS SO
WHAT THE REALLY INTERESTING
PART IS GOING TO BE IS MORE.
HOPKINS FIRST WEEK IS BACK
GETTING BACK IN THE STARTING
QUITE SOME TIME. NG AT US FOR
HE'S WALKING UP BEHIND JIM AND
JUST GIVING HIM THE SHOULDER
RUB ONE MORE WEEK THAT WAS
HOPKINS ON THE FANTASY BENCH
HERE I'M EXCITED ABOUT HOPKINS
I THINK IT IS A BIT OVERSTATED
IT WAS JUST A MATTER OF TYLER
EMERY SPREADING THE BALL
AROUND.
THERE REALLY IS ONLY ONE VAULT
BUT COME ON.
IT'S HOPKINS.
THEY PAID HIM ALL THAT MONEY
FOR REASON HE'S GOING TO BE
INVOLVED THE REAL QUESTION WILL
BE HOPKINS ON ONE SIDE AND HE'S
IN THE SLOT ARE THEY GOING TO
DO IT WITH MORE OFF OF THE
FIELD.
WORRY ABOUT THAT NEXT WEEK THIS
WEEK THOUGH IF YOU NEED A WI
RECEIVER HE'S SETTING UP
BRILILLIANTLY TH THE SLOT
AGAINST THE SEAHAWKS DEFENSE IN
ANY METRIC YOU WANT TO LOOK AT.
SHOULD I START JASON?
>> IT DEPENDS IT'S ONE OF THOSE
THIN WHERE I GET IT HE'S HARD
TO RANK MORE THAN 10 OR 12
TITANS BECAUSE WHEN YOU START
LOOKING PAST 10 OR 11 TIEDOWNS,
ALL OF THE SUDDEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT GUYS THAT HAVE MORE
SNAPS BUT HE'S KIND OF BREAKING
THE MOLD OF EVERYTHING WE
THOUGHT WE KNEW ABOUT TIGHT
ENDS.
HE'S NOT UP THERE BUT HE IS
GETTG THE FOFOOTBALL  FOR
I HAVE JASON RANKED ASAS MY
OVERALL TIGHT END THIS WEEK.
LIKE DALTO
WITH THAT SAID HENRY AND GERALD
EVERETT T I'M STILGOING TO GO
TOWARDS THOSE GUYS I DON'T
THINK HE'S GOING TO BE GETTING
THOSE TOUCHDOWN RUNS EVERY
SISINGLE WEEAS IMPRESSIVE AS
THAT PERFORMANCE WAS.
BENJAMIN ISN'T GOING TO LAST
LONG YOU'RE NOT WRONG.
IT'S A WEEKLY OUT HERE.
WITH JAMES CONNER AGAIN LIKELY
SIDELINED AT LEAST THIS WEEK IF
NOT A FEW MORE HE'S ALADY
RULED OUT.
HE'S ALREADY IN THE TOP 15 AT
LEAST FOR WEEK SIX SO I AR
YOU.
YOU DON'T NEED TO PICK THEM UP.
THEY REALLY HAVE A LONGER
POTENTIAL.
HE CAN BE THAT GUY FOR YOU AT
LEAST IN WEEK SIX IS NOT A
LITTLE BIT BEYOND.
THE SECOND QUARTERBACK THAT HAS
BEEN DISAPPOINTING.
JUST 18 AFTER FIVE WES OF
ACTION HE DID GET US A NICE
LITTLE PERFORMANCE.
COMING UP THAT WEEK THREE
FINISHES OUTSIDE THE TOP 2626 A
THAT WEEK THERE'S BEEN A
VARIETY OF PROBLEMS HERE.
SECOND LOWEST MARK OF HIS
CAREER.
EVERY AREA OF THE FIELD SHORT,
INTERMEDIATE HE'S BEEN RANKING
OUOUTSIDE THTOP QUARTERBACKS
THERE'S ALSO THE REALITY THAT
IS HURT.
THEY'RE CALLING IT A SIMILAR
INJURY TO WHAT HE HAD TO DEAL
WITH LAST  YEAR
HE WAS ABLE TO OVERCOME A LOT
OF THAT BUT DON'T FORGET AS
IMPRESSIVE AS THAT GAME WAS
AGAINST TAMPA BAY COMING UP
WITH 400 YARD SERIOUS QUESTIONS
ABOUT THAT ARM STRENGTH IF YOU
CAN BE THAT SAME GUY WE'VE ALL
SEEN THE PHYSICAL LIMITATIONS
BEFORE ABLE TO SEE OVER THE LINE
SO IF YOU DO TAKE AWAY, TAKE
THEM DOWNFIELD I THINK IT DOES
MAKE MORE SENSE WHY HE HAS
STRUGGLED ENOUGH ALL READY.
IT'S BEEN FIVE WEEKS WITH THE
DENVER BRONCOBRAND-NEW GROUP
A WIDE RECEIVER'S SO A LO
GOING ON WITH THAT ONCE AGAIN --
LET'S GO TO THE PANIC WEEK.
I'M NOT COMPLETELY FREAKING OUT
ON THAT EXPERIENCE JUST YET IT
HASN'TEEN GOOD.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH AN INVESTMENT
ON THIS QUARTERBACK ANYMORE WE
JUST NEED HIM TO BE AVERAGE HOW
DOES HE GET ACROSS THAT FOR THE
FIRST FIVE WEEKS OF THE SEASON?
WE STILL HAVE SATIN.
GREG BASED OFF OF WHAT WEWE SAW
LAST WEEK A LITTLE BIT OF JUICE
FROM GORDON.
I WOULD NOT BE SURPRISED THAT
THE BRONCOS ARE IN THE SHOOT
OUT OR HAVE THE AFC LAST WITH
NOT HAVING THE RESOURCES TO RUN
THE BALL.
YOU MIGHT HAVE ENOUGH OF THE
BALL TO MAKE UP FOR BUT HE
NEEDS A LOT OF THINGSTO GO HIS
WAY SO I WILL SAY SIMILAR
SENTIMENT WHERE THEY ARE
COMPTELY UNUSABLE THE REST OF
THE YEAR BUT THE DAYS OF
LOOKING AT YOUR LINE OF YOUR
VESSEL WILSON COMPLETELY
DISREGARDING THE MATCHUP I DO
BELIEVE THOSE ARE OVER.
FIND A SECOND QUARRBACK DON'T
BE AFRAID YOU GO MATCHUP BY
MATCHUP OVER THERE COMPLETELY
PANICKED AGAIN I THINK THERE'S
ENOUGH TALENT IN THE OFFENSE TO
GET T US ALL THE WAY AROUND.
NOT PROMISING AND EXPECTING
THIS TO BE THE TOP 10 OFFENSE A
LOT OF US WERE HOPING IT WOULD
BE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
DANNY R JAMEIS WINSTON. JAMISON
IS LOOKING LIKE HE'S GETTING
BACK THERE HE'S ILL PLAYING
WITH THE FRACTURE. IF WE CAN
GET EVEN LIKE TWO OF THESE WIDE
RECEIVER'S BACK I WILL BE FINE
GOING TO HIM OTHERWISE I THINK
IT WILL BE AN OFFENSIVE EFFORT
COMPLETELY CENTERED AROUND
RUNNING THE BALL.
THAT'S WHAT IT WAS LAST YEAR
BEFORE THEY GOT THESE RECEIVERS
WITH THE HEAVY OFFENSE IN THE
NFL.
HE WAS UNDER CENTER UNDER SIX
LAST SEASON.
HE IS ACTUALLY IT'S FUN TO CALL
HIM DANNY BUT THE REASON THEY
WANT TO O PLAY HIM IS BECAUSE O
HIS LEGS SO THE HIGHEST RUSHING
PAYS ON THE SEASON RIGHT NOW IN
TERMS OF TOTAL ATTEMPTS SO WE
WILL TALK MORE ABOUT DANIEL
JOS. EGAME GET BY BUT I WOULD
TAKE JAMIE'S WITH  ANEWAND
MICHAEL THOMAS THIS WEEK.
>> RUSSELL WILSON OR GENO SMITH
THIS WEEK WHAT A TIME TO BE
ALIVE CAN YOU IMAGINE YOU'VE
BEEN ASKING THIS QUESTION A
MONTH AGO BUT 'S A VERY
REASONAB QUESTION JUST
COMPLETELY DOMINATING OUT THERE
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH HE NEEDS
TO POST TOP 10 TOP FIVE
QUARTERBACK NUMBERS.
WE JUST HAVE TO LOOK AT
OURSELVES AND SAY HE IS A TOP
10 QUARTERBACK OF THE YEAR.
I AM GOING TO GET GENO SMITH
RIGHT HERE THIS ONE IS MORE SO
BASESED ON WHAT I TALKED ABOUT
THE TCHUP NOT THAT I HAVE HIM
EVERY SINGLE WEEK THE REST OF
THE SEASON IT HAS A POTENTIAL
PASS HAPPY SHOOT UP BUT THE
ARIZONA CARDINALS DEFENSE
HASN'T SHOWED THEY ARE SLOWING
DOWN THE PASSING ATTACKS I WILL
TAKE THAT OVER HIS TRIP DURING
THE COMPANY WITH LOS ANGELES
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
GEORGE SHOULD I KEEP THEM?
>> THAT'S A GREAT TRANSITION.
HE ACTUALLY IS OUR NEXT PLAYER
WE WILL TATALK ABOUT WHETHER WE
SHOULD RELAX OR PANIHERE AND
I REALLY DO THINK THIS COULD BE
FOR GEORGE.
A COUPLE OF REASONS HERE LIVE.
COMING UP WITH AJ HE'S BEEN
TRAVELING A LOT MORE THIS YEAR.
HE'S BEEN COMING UPALL WEEK
ING A PRETTY GOOD JOB MICHAEL
THOMAS HAD TWO TOUCHDOWNS ON
WEEK ONE BUT COOPER CAME UP ON
THE LOSING SIDE OF THINGS JUST
IN GENERAL EVEN IF THE GUYS ARE
ABLE TO WIN OKAY IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS OF THE GREAT
OFFENSE CAN'T BE GREAT DEFENSE
WHICH JUST LIKE IN BASKETBALL
STILL NOT AN EASY MATCHUP BUT
CONSISTENTLY IT'S THE OTHER TOP
RECEIVER THAT WILL START
FALLING OUT AWAY FROM AJ.
COMING UP FOR OVER 100 YARDS.
YET 76 YARDS.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
IT COULDBE SAMUEL THIS WEEK.
HE IS GOING TO BLOW UP AND I AM
GOING TO LEAN TOWARDS HIM
BECAUSE THE OBVIOUS DEFENSE
DOWN ALL SEASON LONG. SLOWING
THEY HAVE THE RECEIVING YARDS.
YES GUYS I'M NOT TOO WORRIED.
WILL SHOW YOU GUYS HOW NOT
WORRIED I AM.
M NOT CONCERNED ABOUT GEORGE
WE ALL GOING TO BE HAPPY.
WE ARE IN THE FIFTH ROUND IN
RST PLACE.
I GET IT HASN'T BEEN IDEAL.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER HE STILL
RUNNING AROUND AND GETS THE JOB
BACK ON A WEEKLY BASIS THIS IS
AN OFFENSE LET'S FACE IT THEY
WERE COMING BACK BUT TREY LANCE
ONLY AS OFLAST WEEKTHEY
ACTUALLY HAD THE BOTTOM FIVE
OFFENSE WITH POINTS SCORED THIS
YEAR FAR BETTER COMING FOR
GEORGE.
COMING WITH THESE MATCHUP
SPECIFICALLY.
TO HAVE ALL SHAPES AND SIZES.
YOU CAN START THE LEFT TACKLE
THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING WE PICK
ONE OR TWO PLAYS WHERE THE GUY
WAS BLOCKING AND WE JUST ASSUME
THAT'S NOT IT HE RAN A ROUTE ON
OVER 80% OF THE DRAWBACKS LAST
WEEK  THAT'S THE NUMBER WE LOOK
FOR TIGHT ENDS.
IT'S NOT GEORGE'S FAULT HE'S AN
INCREDIBLE BLOCKER AND AN
INCREDIBLE RECEIVER I MAINTAIN
IT THE ALIENS INVADED US TO
MOUND FORSTER TO DO A SPACE JAM
THING  GEORGE WOULD BE OUR
TIGHT END.
TRAVIS IS AWESOME.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ABILITY TO
BLOCK WE HAVE A BETTER OFFENSE
ON THE PLANET.
HE'S COMING IN THE FANTASY
LINEUP.
SHOULD I PANIC?
IT'S NOT GREAT FOR THE NUMBER
ONE WIDE RECEIVER IN TERMS OF
TARGETS AND DECEPTIONS.
I WILL SAY FOR RIGHT NOW HE
STILL HAS THAT HAMSTRING INJURY.
I DON'T THINK HE'S GOING TO BE
TOO LONG.
I WOULD BE SURPRISED IF HE WAS
THAT GUY MOVING FORWARD.
IS MUCH AS WE DO EVEN AS THE
HEAD COACH WANTS TO FOCUS ON
THAT. WE DO HAVE THEN  REALLY
HAVE BEEN THERE.
THE RECENT YEARS THE NUMBER ONE
IN THE NFL DROPBOX.
THAT'S ENOUGH TO GET OUT THERE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE GUYS
LIKE THOMAS NOT COMING IN AS
HEAVILY AS WE THOUGHT WE MIGHT.
DAWSON IS DROPPABLE RIGHT?
IT'S JUST A MATTER IF HE SO
BANGED UP.
HE DID HAVE THE GO LINE
FUMBLE BUT HE WAS OPEN FOR A
TOUCHDOWN HE'S JUST NOT THAT
GUY OUT THERE THEY PLAYED
DAWSON.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE A FUTURE
ROLE.
FOR TALKING ABOUT GEORGE'S LEFT
TACKLE.
HE WAS THONE TO EVEN RUN A
ROUTE AROUND 60% OF THE
DRAWBACKS.
DAWSON NEEDS TO BE ON THE
FANTASY STRETCH OF THE
IMAGINATATION. SHLD I START HIM
OVER KYLE?
>> NOT QUITE.
THATWE GOT THERE WE WILL TALK
ABOUT KYLE RIGHT NOW LET'S GET
INTO THE TIDE AND 23 ON THE E
SEON.
I'M NOT FEELING GOOD ABOUT THE
FALCONS OFFENSE AT ALL SOMEHOW
THERE THE 10TH-RANKED OFFENSE
THIS SEASON BUT THE PROBLEM FOR
ME -- IT'S FINE.
WE'VE SEEN HIM OUT THERE WITH
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES.
ITIT'S GOINGNGTO BE JAKE INSTEA
OF KYLE.
WE HAVE TAKEN HIM OUT OF THE
EQUATION HE'S GIVING US
EVERYTHING.
COMING UP WITH FOUR FINISHES.
COMING UP WITH BACK TO BACK
GAMES OUTSIDE OF THE TOP 50.
GET THE ATLANTA FALCONS.
HE'S COMING UP WITH DRAKE LONDON
WHICH IS SO RIDICULOUS BUT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO FOCUS HERE ON
KYLE.
AGAIN IT COMES DOWN TO THE BALL
AND UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T TRUST
MARCUS TO BE LIKE RYAN OR
SOMEONE THAT WILL HIT RECEIVERS
ON THE LIMITED VOVOLUME THIS
SEASON ONLY THE E FALCS AND THE
BEBEARS HAVEBEEN RUNNING THE
FOOTBALL ON 50% OF THE PLAYS
EVEN IF YOU EXCLUDE THAT TIME
SITUATION.
JUST FOUR TOUCHDOWNS HE'S ONLY
AVERAGING 185 PASSING YARDS
THOSE JUST AREN'T THE SORT OF
NUMBERS WE CAN EXPECT LET ALONE
TWO HIGH-END.
YOU CAN TELL BY THE TONE OF MY
VOICE THINGS ARE LOOKING GREAT
WE CAN SEE HOW THEY ARE WITH
OUR PANIC METER.
>> IT'S RED, NOT GOOD.
IT SAYS KYLE.
I STILL BELIEVE IN THE TALENT
DOES SEEM LIKE THE HAMSTRING
INJURY IS GOING TOBE LONG-TERM.
HE EXPECTCTS TO PLAY.
HETILL GOING TO BE INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT TO GET OUT OF YOUR
TOP SIX TIGHT ENDS MORE WEEKS
THAN NOT IT'S JUST UNFNFORTUNAT
WE DRAFTED THE GUY IN THE THIRD
ROUND BEFORE THE SHOW WE WERE
JUST TALKING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
NOT HAVING WHAT HE MADE IN
AUGUST AND EARLY SEPTEMBEBER.
THAT WOULD BE ONE THING I WANT
TO STRESS.
OVERALL EXPECTATIONS.  AND D
DON BENCH, DON'T SELL LOW JUST
BECAUSE YOUR PEST OFF.
HE IS STILL AN INCREDIBLY
TALENTED TIGHT END WE SHOULD
HAVE SOMETHING DAYS AHEAD.
YET THE EFFICIENCY INVOLVED.
I REALLY DO THINK SO.
IS VOLUME REALLY HAS STILBEEN
FINE.
HE STILL HASN'T HAD THE SAME
SUCCESS.
THEY WERE THE FIRST WORST WHEN
TRYING TO THROW 20+ YARDS
DOWNFIELD.
ANYONE'S IDEA OF A TOP-FIVE UNIT
ADD HIM TO THAT EQUATION. YOU
THEY PROGRESS TO MORE OFOF A
MIDDLEF THE PUCK.
IS MUCH AS THAT HASN BEEN
GREAT ON A WELY BASIS WE ARE
STILL TAING ABOUT A GUY FRESH
OFF OF ONE OF THE MOST
IMPRESSIVE ROOKIE SEASONS IN
NFL HISTORY.
THE VOLUME THERE I DON'T THINK
OVERNIGHT HE BECAME BAD AT
FOOTBALL.
IT'S A WEEKLY TOP 10 OPTION.
TAKING THEM OUT OF THE TOP FIVE
I WI COMPLETELY DISAGREE WITH
YOU THERE.
NOW JUST-IN-TIME -- TIME TO
PANIC.
I WOULD JUST SAY THE OFFENSE
UNFORTUNATELY TREVOR LAWRENCE
IS NOT LOOKING LIKE THE SAME
OVERALL WHAT HE LOOKED LIKE.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM HERE.
WE HAVE RISTIAN NOT EXACTLY
COMING UP WITH ONE OF THEM.
WE DO HAVE JONES AND EVAN.
COMING UP INTO THE PASSING
GAME.
UNFORTUNATELY WITH TREVOR
LAWRENCE THE HIGH SCORE PASSER
AMONG THE QUALIFIED
QUARTERBACKS.
WE JUST HAVEN'T SEEN TREVOR
LAWRENCE BE CONSISTENT ENOUGH
FOR THE DE RECEIVER. I SAW
CHRISTIAN AS A TOP 24 WIDE
RECEIVER.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO SETT IN
AS MORE FOR THE WIDE RECEIVER
AS OPPOSED TO THAT OPTION.
NO SIMILAR NTIMENT FOR KYLE
IT SUCKS WE CAN'T BE HIGHER BUB
STILL A QUALITY GUY THAT SHOULD
BE STARTING ON THE FANTASASY
LINEUPS MORE THAN NOT.
YOU GUYSARE JUST SETTING ME UP
SO WELL IN THESE TRANSITIONS.
LET'S GO TO THE RUNNING BACKS
HERE WITH 37 HIMSELF.
IT'S BECAUSE OF HIS UPWARD
TRAJECTORY USAGE AND HAS BEEN A
LITTLE BIT GAME INDUCED.
BEATING DOWN ONCOLTON AND
ANOTHER POSITIONON.
COMING UP AND TRYINGO MAKE
EVERYTHING LOCKED IN.
TO S CREDIT HE RIPPED OFF AT
37.
YOU LOOK GOOD OUT THERE.
COMING DOWN BUT WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE WHE SEASON WITH THAT
SAMPLE SIZE, HE'S BEEN THE
BETTER RUNNING BACK.
MAYBE YOU'RE NOT A FAN.
IF YOU WANT, FINE.
4.9 JAMES ROBINSON.
GET THE CONTACT SU HAS MORE?
WHO'S FORCING MORE MISSED
TACKLES?
HE'S GETTING THE RUN 1.36
VERSUS 0.58.
I DON'T LIKE TAKING AWAY
PLAYERS MAKE PLAYS THEY ARE IN
THOSE PLAYS THEY HAVE BEEN IT'S
ANNOYING TO ME.
YOU SAW THE FOURTH AND ONE
TOUCHDOWN AS IT HAPPENED.
ANYBODY COULD'VE RUN THROUGH
AND GOTTEN THOSE 50 YARDS.
TAKE AWAY THOSE WIDE-OPEN
TOUCHDOWN RUNS THAT ROBINSON
HAS HAD WITH 2.97 YARDS PER
CARRY IS THAT A FACTOR FOR THE
OFFENSE?
ABSOLUTELY.
THEY WERE GOOD OVER THE LAST
TWO WEEKS DURING THE FIRST OF
THE SEASON BUT THAT'S ANOTHER
FACT THAT WILL HELP THEM
BECAUSE HE OUT SNAPS JAMES
ROBINSON WHEN THEY ARE PLAYING
FROM BEHIND WHICH ALL OF THE
SUDDEN IS LOOKING MORE AND MORE
LIKELY FOR THE EMERGENCE OF THE
JAGUARS OFFENSE SO IT THAT
LET'S GET OUR PANIC METER.
I'M GOING TO BE YELLOW HERE
RELATIVE TO OUR PRESEASON
EXPECTATIONS.
ROBIBINSON ISN GOING ANYWHERE
THTHEY CAN ILL GO EITHER WAY
WITHTH THEMBEING EITHER  REAL
GOOD OR REALLY BAD BUT JUST AT
THAT HE LOOKS GREAEAT OUT THERE
COMING OFF OF THAT INJURY.
GOING INTO THIS YEAR NOT A
MINIMUM WE DO HAVE AN EXPLOSIVE
PA WITH TWO RUNNING BACK
COMMITTEES.
I'M NOT SAYING HE CAN GO T
THERE ON A WEEKLY BASIS AND
FIRE HIM UP.
THAT WHY WE ARE IN A YELLOW
STAGE OF PANIC.
HE'S NOT THE GUY WE DRAFTED HIM
TO BE.
YORE GOING TO HAVE AN AWFULLY
HARD TIME BRINGING IT BACK.
STILL A FLEX OPTION.
GOGOD FORBIDSOMETHING HAPPENS
ALL THE SUDDEN WE COULD BE
TALKING ABOUT TRAVIS AS A
WEEKLY TOP OPTION.
LOOK AT GUYS LIKE STEPHENSON.
YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN ONE
INJURY HAPPENS TWO OFTHESE
RUNNING BACK BACK FIELDS IS
WHAT'S SO BIG IT'S A NEW GAME
THESE DAYS WE CAN'T EXPECT
EVERY RUNNING BACK IN THE YEAR
00 HE HAD 19 DIFFERENT
RUNNING BACKS IN AT LEAST 300
TOUCHES.
LAST SEASON THERE WAS FOUR.
GUGUYS IN LOANGELES, IT'S
SAPPOIING WE CAN'T USE THEM
THE WAY WITH THAT WE WOULD USE
THEM I KNOW IT SUCKS THAT WE
USE THE FOURTH-ROUND PICK IT'S
ONLY GIVING YOU A LITTLE BIT OF
FLEX VALUE BUT THAT'S A VE
VALUABLE ASSET YOU HAVE TO
OVERPAY IT TO GET THEM A FEW
MONTHS AGO.
SEEK OR KENNETH WALKER THIS WEEK
THE ST OF THE SEASON TAKING
US RIGHT HERE INTO OUR NEXT
RUNNING BACK JUST THE 38 ON THE
YEAR AND SIMILAR TO ALLOW THESE
PLAYERS -- FOOTBALL IS
OBVIOUSLY A TEAM SPORT ANYONE
SHOULD TRY TO SPEW SOME
SHENANIGANS HE TS FINE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF RED FLAGS
RIGHT HERE.
THIS COWBOYS OFFENSE ISN'T
NEARLY AS GOOD AS LAST SEASON.
IT NOT JUST BECAUSE HE'S ON
THE CENTER WITH PRESCOTT 24th
IN SCORING THIS YEAR 27 FOR THE
OFFENSE OFINE.
THERE'S A LOT OF PROBLEMS GOING
ON ALSO THEY  ARSTARTING TO
AFFECT ELLIOTT.
WE TALKED ABOUT GEORGE IN THAT
SPECTACULAR. HE'S NOT
HE MIGHT BE THE LEFT TACKLE IN
THIS CONVERSATION HE IS ONLY ON
PACE TO CATCH 17 PASSES.
CATCHES IN 17 GAMES.
THAT WAS WHEN HE WAS SUSPENDED
AND HE ONLY PLAYED 10 GAMES SO
REALLYLY THEY AREITHER LIVING
IN THE PAST BLOCK OR THEY ARE
THROWING THE FOOTBALL IS
AVERAGING 4.18 RUSHING YARDS
MORE THAN ELLIOTT THIS SEASON
SO NOW I DON'T THINK THE
COWBOYS WILL TURN IT OVER TO
TONY THEY ARE TOO PROUD TO BE
FAIR ETT AND HIS ABILITY TO
GET THE SHORT YARDS AND TOUGH
YARDS AND PAST BLOCK HE STILL
DOES A LOT OF REALLY IMPORTANT
THINGS HE JUST DOESN'T DO THEM
AT A HIGH ENOUGH LEVEL TO
WARRANT THAT CONTRACT BUT WHAT
RUNNING BACK DOES WANT A
CONTRACT SOME MIGHT ASK THAT'S
A PRETTY FAIR QUESTION.
A LOT OF PROBLEMS GOING ON AND
WITH THAT WE GO TO OUR PANIC
METER.
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE COWBOYS
OFFENSE?
THEY LOOKED ABSOLUTELY TERRIBLE
FOR THE FIRST 15 MINUTES OF
THIS GAME JUST BECAUSE OF THAT,
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THAT ONE WIDE RECEIVER OUT
THERE.
THEY WERE NOT DOING THEM ANY
FAVORS AS MUCH AS MICHAEAEL HAS
COME BACK AND LOOK AT I DON'
THINK WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
SAME TOP FIVE SCORING OFFENSE
THAT WE THOUGHT WE WERE BEFORE
THE SEASON THIS IS A DEFENSES
MINDED TEAM WITH ONE OF THE
BEST PLAYERS IN THE NFL.
GOING AT 15-20 CARRIES PER GAME.
HE'S BEHIND GUYS LIKE DANIEL
AND MONTGOMERY.
THE OVERALL USAGE. HE CEASES TO
EXIST OKAY.
I STILL THINK THEY THERE COULD
BE SLIGHTLY BETTER DAYS AHEAD.
IT'S GOING TO GET ZEKE INTO THE
LOW-END WITH THAT CONVERSATION.
LOOKING AT HIM AS A LOCKED-IN
PERSON OR OVER.
NO. NG UP WITH ROBINSNSON.
WE ARE NOT BUYING OUT ROBINSON.
LET'S TALK ABOUT HOW MUCH WE
SHOULD BE PANICKING ABOUT THE
WIDE RECEIVER TOO.
THE BIG THING TO REMEMBER ABOUT
ROBINSON, IT'S NOT THAT HE IS
TH HE HAS NOT BEEN THE WORST
WIDE RECEIVER IN THE ENTIRE NFL
AMONG THE GUYS THAT GOT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO T ON THE
FIELD.
84 WIDE RECEIVERS WITH AT LEAST
15 TARGETS.
COMING UP 83rd.
TARGETED BEING OUT RUN. THE
THAT LAST ONE HAS EARNED
TARGETS AT A LOWER RATE OF THE
ROUTE AND ROBINSON.
WE CANGO BACK TO AUGUST OUT
HOW THE ROUTE RUNNING IS GOING
TO BE UTILIZED BY STAFFORD
HAVING THEM OUT THERE WE ARE
STILL WAITING TO SEE THOSE GUYS.
AVERAGING FEWER TARGETS NOW
WITH ROBINSON AT THE 25 YARDS
WITH FOUR MINUTES FIVE GAMES
THIS SEASON.
25 YARDS IT'S NOT THAT HE'S
BEEN RELATIVELY BAD WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE WIDE RECEIVER
THIS HAS BEEN UNUSABLE AND THIS
IS WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT.
DOESN'T LOOK GOOD THOUGHGH WH
YOU ADD ON E FACT THIS OFFENSE
-- MATTHEW STAFFORD IS IN
PLAYING GET.
HE TARGETS COOPER AT A HIGHER
RATE THAN ANY OTHER TEAMMATES
IN THE NFL I KNOW THAT'S THAT.
COOPER IS A LITTLE BIT LIKE
BRYANT COMBINING FOR 81 POINTS.
HE'S BEING FORCE-FED THE BALL
TOO THAT'S WHY HE'S THE TIGHT
END ON THE SEASON.
WE HAVE TYLER HIGBEE REMAINING
JUST A LITTLE BIT HOPEFUL
EVENTUALLY THEY WILL TAKE YOU
OVER THE BACKFIELD OTHERWISE,
NO.
I WILL SHOW YOU HOW MUCH I
DON'T FEEL GOOD ABOUHIM.
BRING UP THE PAC METER.
I GOT EIGHT PLAYERS FOR YOU
GUYSYS HE'S THONLY ONE IN DARK
RED.
WE HAVE MORE SHALLOW WHICH WE
COULD CUT HIM.
HE'S NOT SOMEONE WE ED TO
KEEP.
IT COULD BE WORSE FOR HIM
CAUSE WE LOOK AT THIS HE
EXPECTS TO COME BACK IN
NOVEMBER MAYBE TO THE RAMS,
MAYBE NOT.
COMING UP IN THE OFFENSE.THE
SEASON.
.FORBID SOMETHING HAPPENS TO
MATTHEW ONE OF THE WORST
QUARTERBACK SITUATIONS IN THE
LEAGUE OVER THERE.
UNFORTUNATELY HE'S NOT GETTING
ANY VOLUME AND I JUST DON'T SEE
ANY REASON TO EXPECT EITHER OF
THOSE FACTORS HAVE CHANGED
ANYTIME SOON.
DJ MOORE IS KILLING ME.
>> HE'S KILLING ALL OF US LET'S
TALK ABOUT THIS HERE WITH THE
NUMBER ONE WIDE RECEIVER BUT
JUST WATCH THE FANTASY THIS
SEASON.
58. ALL, THE WIDE RECEIVER AT
21-94 ON THE YEAR.
THE PROBLEM GUYS IS THAT DJ IS
NOT GETTING ENOUGH OPPORTUNITY
TOAKE UP FOR THAT EFFICIENCY
THAT THE OFFENSE BROUGHT OUT I
WOULD NEVER CALL DJ A BAD
RECEIVER WE HAVE SEEN WAY TOO
MUCH TO SUGGEST THE OPPOSITE OF
THAT BUT  YOU HAVE A GOOD
RECEIVER AND A BAT OFFENSE,
THAT'S NOT GOING THE BALL VERY
MUCH NOW ALL THE SUDDEN THE
TALENT DOESN'T HAVE MANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO RUN OUT IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
DJ HAS A TEAM-HIGH 37 TARGET.
ROBBIE ANDERSON AT 27. M.
WOULD YOU GUYS HAVE GUESSED
THAT ROBBIE ANDERSON LEADS THE
PANTHERS IN RECEIVING YARDS?
IT COMES DOWN TO THE FACT THAT
IT'S NOT EVEN THAT SURPRISING
THAT HE HASN'T PUT UP BETTER
NUMBERS IF YOU LOOK AT HIS
WORKLOAD WE HAVE  SOME EXPECTED
FANTASY POINTS ALL IT DOES IS
LOOK AT THE EXACT TARGETETS WE
GOT DOWNFIELD.
END ZONE THEY TAKE AWAY WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENS SO WE CAN SEE
WHAT THE WORKLOAD OF ALL THESE
GUYS ARE.
THEY HAVE THE WIDE RECEIVER AT
40.
THAT'S BETTER THAN THE 49 RIGHT
THERE I DON'T HATE FIND THAT ON
DJ BECAUSUSE WE CAN'T LOOK ATHI
LIKE ARE YOU GETTING IN A LOWER
THAN IT IS?
I'M NOT ALL THAT CERTAIN HE'S
GOING TO COME UP TO THE TOP 24
AND TO BEAIR I'M DOING THEM
UNDER THE BUS A LOT BECAUSE
TERRIBLE EFFICIENCY MEASURES
IT'S A TERRIBLE TWO-WAY STREET
TRYING TO CATCH THE BALL HE'S
ALSO POPPING UP. THIS YEAR THE
ONLY GUYS WORSE THAN DJ IN
TERMS OF GUARDS PER TARGET IS
ROBINSON AND PUNTER HE'S
DEALING WITH A BUNCH OF
INJURIES  LET'S GO TO OUR PANIC
METER.
>> NOT QUITE AS BAD AS ALLEN
ROBINSON IT'S JUST A REALITY
THAT RIGHT NOW WE HAVE AN
INJURED PERSON.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO BETTER THAN
A NON-INJURED PERSON.
I'M A HUGE FAN.
I LOST EVERY SNAPBACK I TOOK
THERE'S A REASON HE WAS IN THE
NFL W THE BIG FORMER HEAD
COACH.IN INTO THE NFL IN THE
FIRST PLACE THAT HELPED HIM.
WE ARE PRAYING THAT SAM COMES
BACK HEALTHY THAT'S THE POINT
WE GOT TO WITH DJ.
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S NOT AN
EFFICIENT ENOUGH OFFENSE IT'S
TOO CROWDED FOR DJ FOR BRANDON
AND HOUSTON.
WHY ARE THEY OVERCOMING IT?
THEY ARE COMPLETE TARGET HOGS
THAT'S N THE CASE WITH DJ
AGAIN I'M NOT PUTTING THE BLAME
ON HIM AND PUTTING IT ON THE
OFFENSE.
UNRTUNELY THOSE THINGS ALL
MATTER WHEN WE ARE TRYING TO
LOOK AT DJ I'M NOT EXPECTING
THGS TO GET BETTER FOR HIM.
ANYTIME SOON.
SO THAT WAS OUR LAST PANIC
SEGMENT. NOW WE ARE GETTIN
SOME FANTASY ADVICE.
PRESENTED BY ATE FARM WITH
THE PERSONAL PRICE PLANS ALL
ABOUT CREATING A PRICE JUST FOR
YOU.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE FACT THAT
TYREEK HILL IS NOT 100% WITH
THAT FOOT INJURY.
THEY DID REPORT ON SUSUNDAY THA
HE'S EXPECTING TO PLAY WITH
PAIN AND STILL BE OUT THERE
THIS WEWEEK.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH OF THAT ON IF
THIS OFFENSE IS GOING TO BE
FANTASTIC WITH THOMPSON IT'S A
BIT ON JAELYN BEING A FREAKISH
TALENT IN HIS OWN AND McDANIEL
THE HEAD COACH IS DOING A GOOD
JOB GETTING HIM THE BALL AND
EASY WAYS.
TOP THREE IN PLAY ACTION I
THINK HE'S TOO GOOD WITH AGAIN
A COACH THAT KNOWS HOW TO GET
THBALL ON THE BENCH.
HE'S STILL A VIABLE WIDE
RECEIVER.
>> MOST COMING UP SINGULAR IT'S
A CLOSE ONE.
I DO LEAN JUST BARELY TOWARD
DYLAN THIS WEEK WEHAVE SEEN
THE USAGE GOING A LITTLE BIT
SIDEWAYS WITH ALL THREE OF
THESE GUYS RANG FAIRLY CLOSE
TOGETHER I FEEL A LOT BETTER IF
YOU DIDN'T MISS PRACTICE ON
WEDNESDAY WITH THIS NEW INJURY.
THEY COME OUT AND SAY ULTIMATELY
HE WAS A TOUCHDOWN FAVORITE AT
HOME IF THIS ISN'T THE WEEK TO
REALLY TARGET HIM AND EXPECT
THAT TO HAPPEN, WHEN WILL IT
HAPPEN FOR AJ DYLAN FROM THE
EAGLES FAN SHOULD I WORRY ABOUT
AARON N JONES?
I DON'T THINK SO.
THE JONES USAGE HAS BEEN
INCREASING ON A WEEKLY BASIS
JUST IN TERMS OF THE BEST
OVERALL RUNNING BACKS THISIS
YEAR.
HE SHOULDN'T BE IN ANYO'S TOP
FIVE.
HE HAS YARDS OUT TO CONTACT WHY
HE HAS THE MISSED TACKLE.
JUST TWO INDEPENDENT SITUATIONS
WE WILL LOOK AT WITH THE
QUARTERBACK AND STUFF LIKE
THAT.
FANTASTIC TALENT THIS YEAR.
HE'S THE NEXT SPECIAL RUNNING
BACK SO WE KNOW HOW GREAT HE IS
AS A RECEIVER STILL DODON'T THI
WE SEE THE BEST VERSION OF THIS
OFFENSE.
I STILL BELIEVE THEY ARE GOING
TO BE CONSISTE WITH THE TOP
FANS IN MORE RECENTTHAN NOT
WILL JONES GIVE US THAT SUPERS
SKYHIGH FEELING?
THAT WILL PROBABLY BE A NO FOR
ME.
STILL SOMEONE YOU'D LIKE TO
HAVE AN ADVANCE.
NEXT WEEK I KNOW YOU GUYS MIGHT
NOT HAVE THAT MANY PROBLEMS
THIS WEEK IN TERMS OF THE
QUARTERBACK'S THEY JUST WEREN'T
USING ALL THAT MUCH ANYWAY.
NEXT WEEK WE HAVE THE BILLS,
THE VIKINGS, THE EAGLES AND THE
RAMS SO A COUPLE OF REASONABLE
OPTIONS IF YOU WANT TO GET
AHEAD OF THE E ME AND COVER
THAT UP.
KENNY GOING UP AGNST THE
DOLPHINS DEFENSE THAT'S THE
BOTTOM FIVE DEFENSE AND THEY
ARE BANGED UP.
THE NUMBER ONE QUARTERBACK
HASN'T COME BACK OFF OF THE
LIST ALL SEASON-LONG.
IT'S NOT GOING AS PLANNED.
AM NOT EXPECTING HIM BACK
ANYTIME SOON.
HE'S NOT REALLY DOING WELL NOW
HE'S TRYING TO PLAY THREE GROIN
INJURY.
IF YOU HAVE YOUR QUARTERBACKS
BOTH BANGED UP I DON'T LIKE
THEIR CHANCE WITH JOHNSON ALL
THAT WELL SO KENNY, YET.
HAS NOT BEEN THE BEST SO FAR WE
DID SEE THOSE INTERCEPTIONS.
I THINK WE HAVE SEEN HIM GIVEN
HIS RECEIVERS HOPEFULLY BACK BY
THEN.
SHOOTITINGP OFSORTS I ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT THEY HAVE THE
TOP FIVE NUMBERS IN THE
QUARTERBACK POSITION.
LOOK AT DANIEL JONES VERSUS
JACKSON.
I WOULD BE THE MOST SURPRISED
TO SEE A POTENTIAL SO THEY CAN
MERGE.
ASSUMING HE AND SOME OF HIS
RECEIVERS ARE HELPING HERE.
THEY HAVE TO GOGO ROUGH IT
AGAIN.
YOU LOOK AT THE SEATTLE
SEAHAWKS DEFENSE THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN TERRIBLE IN THE PAST.
THIS IS THE MATCHUP WE WANT TO
GET GOING ON.
WE DIDN'T KNOW IF HE WAS
COMPLETELY DISPLACED ACROSS THE
TOP. HE DID AND AGAIN THE
DEFENSE COMING UP FOR THE WIDE
RECEIVER'S LINED UP THE 32nd
PASSING TOUCHDOWN.
100%.
WE JUST IMMEDIATELY JUMP ON
TOP.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE COMPLETELY
IDEAL.
CHIMERIC YOU JUST HAVE TO LIVE
WITH THAT.
MAYBE THAT WILL HELP YOU LUCK.
CURTIS SAMUEL AM STILL GOING TO
GO WITH CURTIS SAMUEL HERE IT'S
MORE OF A FACTOR OF VOLUME
HERE.
IT'S NOT HELPING US AS MUCH  IN
FANTASY.
THAT SNACK LAST WEEK CAUGHT HIM
DOWNFIELD TWO WEEKS AGO.
GETTING THE TOUCHDOWN
UNFORTUNATELY GETTING A BETTER
BALL FROM JUSTIN FIELD.
HE STILL VERY MUCH A GREAT WIDE
RECEIVER BUT CURTIS SAMUEL JUST
GETTING FORCE THAT TARGETS IN
THAT LOW AVERAGE TARGET DEPTH
AREA.
ESPECIALLY IN FULL PPR. 2
THAT'S A TOUGH ONE.
I'M GOING TO LEAN TOWARDS
DOBBINS.
BOTH OF THESE BACK FIELDS ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THREE
RUNNING BACKS.
GUESS YOU HAD THE MOST SNAPS?
NOT GIBSON NOT RYAN ROBINSON.
WASHINGTON STARTS TO TRAIIN
THAT GE BUT THERE'S THREE
RUNNING BACKS NOT JUST ONE OR
TWO.
I REALLY SEE ROBINSON HAVING A
PRETTY EQUAL CARRY JUST
ALIGNMENT WITH EACH OTHER AT
THAT POINT THE BALTIMORE RAVENS
OFFENSE I WILL TAKE THE RAVENS
WOULD I TRADE JEFF WILSON?
YES.
GREAT TRADE.
I WOULD DO THAT.
THE THING WITH JEFF WILSON HE'S
BEEN DOING WELL BUT HE'S BACK
ON PRACTICE TH WEEK.
THEY ARE ALREADY STARTING TO
GET INTOTHE WORKLOAD. THEY ARE
TIED WITH THE RAVENS AND ARE
DEAD LAST WITH THE RUNNING
BACK.
WE REALLY NEED ONE RUNNING BACK
FOR SAN FRANCISCO IN ORDER TO
EXPECT ANYTHING CONSISTENT FOR
FANTASY PRODUCTION.
COMING UP WITH THAT KNEE INJURU.
HE'S GOING TO COME OUT THE
ENTIRE SEASON.
SOMEONE WITH COOPER THAT IS
LEADING THE TOP 10 SCORING
OFFENSE WE ALREADY GOT SOME
GREAT BOOMS FROM  CO.
I THINK HE'S A FAIRLY
REASONABLE STARTER IN ANY GIVEN
WEEK.
HE'S DOWN THE STRETCH FOR THE
FANTASY PLAYOFFS.
HE STILL GOING TO BE THE
INCIDENT.
CHEVY SCARED ABOUT JAMES CONNER?
THEY PUT HIM ON THE IR.
THEY HAVE BOTHLOWED BOAT
LOADS A TIME.
COMING UP BUT THAT INJURY.
EXPERIENCING ANOTHER INJURY I
HOPE YOU WERE ABLE TO GET
BENJAMIN IN THE MEANTIME AND
THAT LAST ONE EVEVERYBODY CLASS
JP.
JUST PANIC.
I THINK U CAN GET DONE WITH
NIXON.
HE LEADS THE NFL WITH PPR R
POINTS PER GAME.
DRAFTING THE TOP 10 RUNNING
BACK NOT THE TOP 15.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S REALLY PRETTY MUCH
EXPLORE WHAT THAT.
HE'S ABLE TO GET THAT THIS YEAR
UNFORTUNATELY HE'S 0 FOR 7 ON
MATCHING ATTEMPTS WITH
TOUCHDOWNS WE DID SEE HIM LAST
WEEK BY ME STARTED GETTING SOME
ROOM TO RUN.
NOT THE MOST AND I UNDERSTAND
IT'S MORE OF AN OFFENSE OF STOP
BUT OVER FIVE LAST WEEK.
EXPECTING BETTER AND BETTER
THINGS WITH THE OFFENSE AND
USAGE IS THERE FOR A PLAYER
THAT WE STILL KNOW IS GOOD.
I'NONOT PACKING ON JOE OR
JOHNSON FOR THAT MATTER.
NO TOUCHDOWNS YET ONLY 53 1/2
YARDS PER GAME I'VE NEVER BEEN
MORE CONFIDENT JOHNSON IS THE
WIDE RECEIVER.
I POST AN ARTICICLE IN MY REPOR
WE NULLIFY TOUCHDOWNS FOR GUYS
THAT ARE OPENING AND DOING A
BAD PASS.
JOHNSON IS ON THIS LIST EVERY
SINGLE WEEK.
USUALLY MULTIPLE OCCASIONS WE
HAD A COUPLE OF TALKS HERE AND
THERE USING THAT INCREDIBLE
ROUTE RUNNING ABILITYDEALING
WITH TOO MUCH OF THAT WITH THAT
EXPERIENCE WITH THAT SAID,
FOLLOW THAT VOLUME FOLLOW THAT
TALENT ON JOHNSON.
GUYS, THAT'S GOING TO WRAP IT
UP HERE ANOTHER EDITION
PRESENTED BY STATE RM.
I ALWAYS  LOVE THOSE GUYS SOME
OF YOU GU